a quiet place is about a family that has  to live as silently as possible or else  horrible things happen whatever is  hunting them is everywhere it's all  throughout the world there's nowhere to  go  the only people this family have to rely  on are each other obviously living  silently is an impossibility they have  to figure out which sounds are safe and  which sounds aren't safe  the father lays down sand paths to keep  everything muted the entire family has  to speak sign language there's a whole  lighting system that they communicate  with this movie it's extremely scary and  so emotional  it's a really intense experience  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you